hallo nachbar was machst du so mit
serdar somuncu heute österreich
hallo nachbar am sonntag wählt ihr
österreicher schon wieder und einmal der
verbietet sich jede piefke arroganz die
ossis sind uns immer um lichtjahre
voraus denken wir nur an milch speisen
und schon vor jahrzehnten sind diese
alten visionäre auf die idee gekommen
familienmitglieder klimaneutral
im keller wurden zu lassen österreich
ist immer auch ein blick in unsere
zukunft wie tief die ultra rechtes
gedankengut ins bürgertum vorgedrungen
ist das ist für unsere fdp noch ein
ferner feuchter traum hier
er hat die fdp endgültig hoffähig
gemacht sebastian kurz ich frage mich
nur warum muss man einen zwölfjährigen
jungen auch noch photoshop nur wochen
nach der affäre will eine neuauflage
seiner koalition mit der fpö nicht
ausschließen warum auch strache der
einzig rechte in der fpö ist ja weg
vorne steht jetzt norbert hofer
verschont ein mann des volkes
was mögen sie so einem hofer
ausländerfeindlichkeit war das motto
frage weil die menschenverachtenden
entgleisungen der letzten monate und
trotzdem steht die fbl wieder bei 20
prozent
andererseits würden sie von diesem mann
keinen gebrauchtwagen kaufen liebe
österreicherinnen liebe österreicher die
letzte bundesregierung war bei den
menschen im land sehr sehr beliebt das
würde viel gearbeitet das würde nicht
gestritten
es ist viel weiter gegangen es wurden
ohne ende falsche oligarchien den auf
ibiza voll gelabert leider nicht durch
geklettert dazu war mein freund strafe
zu besoffen von der fpö lernen heißt
siegen lernen deren plakate sind so gut
wie werden noch jahrzehnte später von
wirbellosen deutschen geklaut hier jörg
haider 1994 und bernd oelkers
facebook-seite heute
wenn sie ganz genau hinschauen erkennen
sie möglicherweise parallelen
ach ja alles schöne fängt mit haider
röcke hosen prellung und nächste woche
bei hallo nachbar dänemark
was soll das eigentlich sein großen
wiese oder richtiges land servus
[Applaus]